هناك رسالة إلى الولايات المتحدة بصفتها
كونغرسًا جديدًا ، سيأتي منزل جديد بقيادة جمهورية ،
وهناك أيضًا رسالة إلى
روسيا ،
نعم بالتأكيد محليًا
كما تعلمون ، كما تعلمون ، ذكر فيل
في مقالته ، أنا الكونغرس
يدرس مشاريع قوانين من شأنها  السماح
بمزيد من المساعدات لأوكرانيا ، وبما أنهم
يفكرون في أن هذا التوقيت لا يمكن أن يكون
أكثر كمالا أه من
وجهة نظر زيلينسكي وبقدر ما يتعلق الأمر بروسيا ،
فإن الشيء الرئيسي هنا بريانا هو
أنه يعزز حقًا تلك
الصلة بين الولايات المتحدة
وأوكرانيا  وهو يرسل رسالة إلى
بوتين بينما يقرر بوتين ما إذا كان
سيشمل بيلاروسيا في مجهوده الحربي ضد أوكرانيا أم لا.
على الصعيدين الدولي والمحلي ،
نرى ذلك في بعض من هذه اللحظات أه المهمة
أه هذا النوع من اللحظات البصرية مثل
هذه المرئيات التي
يحب بوتين إرسالها.  رسالة n
وأتساءل ما الذي تعتقد أنه سيفعله
ردًا على
ذلك ، فهذا سؤال جيد حقًا أعتقد أن
ما قد نحاول القيام به هو أنه قد يحاول
تشويه سمعة uh zielinski بطريقة
أو بأخرى وليس لديها  لكي تكون
بمعلومات حقيقية يمكن أن يكون بمعلومات كاذبة
سيحاول القيام بشيء من
هذا القبيل أه ربما تعرف من خلال
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن هذا نوع من الاستجابة الضعيفة
مقارنة بالحقيقة الفعلية
لزيارة أه
واشنطن والقيام بأول زيارة خارجية لواشنطن سولينسكي
منذ ذلك الحين  بداية الحرب أه لذا
أعتقد أن ما قد يفعله بوتين هو أنه قد
يضاعف جهوده مع إيران أه قد
يحاول تسريع إنتاج
أنظمة أسلحته وقد يحاول أيضًا العمل على وضع
أكثر من نوع المسودة
من حيث  التجنيد الإجباري للروس
وحملهم على القول حقًا إن الغرب
يتحد علينا ، لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى
المزيد من القوات ، لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى القتال
بقوة أكبر في أوكرانيا ، ولا أعتقد
أن هذا قد يكون ناجحًا كما يفعل
ردًا على هذا